yeah look i think there's more than just
joe manson and christian cinema that are
don't want to get rid of the filibuster
and think some of these ideas go beyond
their comfort level but if you watch
what's happened to joe manchin and
kirsten cinema when they stepped out
there's a lot of people that are saying
you know what you know i'm just going to
vote with a pack and sort of keep my
head down it's not going to pass anyway
thank god for christian cinema and joe
manchin and so these are people that are
voting yes but hoping for no and and the
fact that two people are willing to step
out and do it kind of gave them the
result they wanted but these guys don't
they don't want to be singled out they
don't want donors threatening them with
primaries they're they're scared and so
i'm not saying that's true of everybody
but yeah there are democrats that view
this as kind of crazy but they're not
going to say it because their base has
become radicalized the people that knock
on doors and make phone calls and and
that they need to mobilize for election
day are demanding whatever the pet issue
at the moment is and they're far outside
the mainstream but if they take those
people on they may not be back and they
certainly don't want the headache
associated with it
where are you at with using the levers
of power at this point when it comes to
you know there's still a lot of kids in
masks in schools here not all the
schools it's a little unclear to me if
that's left to the counties at this
point or the mayor's or there's
obviously some level of school choice
and private public school all of that
what do you think should be happening
are you trying to push one way or
another or where are you at
yeah you know ultimately in my view i i
think one of the things that this
pandemic revealed is the importance of
local government and local control to
make those decisions and so right now at
the state levels the schools are being
told you can't have a mass mandate so as
an example the public schools here in
miami-dade have a mass mandate for
employees but not for the kids and
there's a lot of reason that private
schools can make their own decisions
right so i have one kid who's in a
public charter school and they don't
have a mass mandate and i have my older
son is in a private catholic high school
and they do but i can tell you a couple
things about it the first is that again
it's a risk and reward balancing
prospect let me be frank like the way
these kids wear the masks on a you know
12 to 20 hour basis whenever around the
school isn't exactly you know the way
you're supposed to wear them if they're
even effective at all in that sense so
that's the reality so you start thinking
it's okay they're not they're not going
to wear the mask the way they're
supposed to anyway all we're doing is
creating an additional irritant um in
their educational setting and so you
hope there's some common sense into how
that's enforced and then i think when
you talk about this omicron variant it
ultimately isn't i mean if you talk to
people who will speak to you honestly
about it the masks aren't going to stop
this this is a highly infectious variant
luckily it's not as severe but it is
highly infectious and there are just
things that aren't going to work against
it and and um so so my view of it is i
leave it to the to the states and the
school boards to make those decisions
but i would hope they would make those
decisions with the best interests of the
kids in mind i'd much i'm much more
worried about them not learning how to
read and write than i am about them not
wearing the mask exactly right you know
with the thing notched over their nose
and and especially since they're not
going to wear it right anyway and the
mask most of the kids are using isn't
even effective against the old variant
not to mention omicron yeah all right
well that's a perfect way to tie up the
whole florida portion so i want to move
a little bit towards national politics
and and what's going on uh right now at
the moment so in these last couple days
obviously we saw this stalemate in the
senate about the voting rights act
you're going to call me crazy i believe
you have to have an id or you should
have an id to vote the democrats
apparently don't believe that and if you
believe it you're racist now there's
this fight over the filibuster you
mentioned a few minutes ago that there
used to sort of be these sane liberals
that you could debate these ideas with
is there anyone left over there i mean i
suspect you probably think joe manchin's
pretty decent at the moment but i mean
when you hear them with these crazy
policies where we're going to have
illegals voting and you don't have to
have an id to vote but you also have to
have a vaccine card to walk into
mcdonald's i mean do you get behind
closed doors with these guys and go what
are you doing
yeah look i think there's more than just
joe manson and chris and cinema that are
don't want to get rid of the filibuster
and think some of these ideas go beyond
their comfort level but if you watch
what's happened to joe manchin and
kirsten cinema when they stepped out
there's a lot of people that are saying
you know what you know i'm just going to
vote with a pack and sort of keep my
head down it's not going to pass anyway
um thank god for christian cinema and
joe manchin and so these are people that
are voting yes but hoping for no
and and the fact that two people are
willing to step out and do it kind of
gave them the result they wanted but
these guys don't they don't want to be
singled out they don't want donors
threatening them with primaries they're
they're scared and so not saying that's
true of everybody but yeah there are
democrats that view this as kind of
crazy but they're not going to say it
because their base has become
radicalized the people that knock on
doors and make phone calls and and that
they need to mobilize for election day
are demanding whatever the pet issue at
the moment is and that are far outside
the mainstream but if they take those
people on they may not be back and they
certainly don't want the headache
associated with it and so i think as
much as anything else the threats
against kirsten cinema and joe manchin
that you've seen
is not so much about kirsten cinnamon
joe manchin it's a message to the other
senators and other members of congress
who may be thinking about stepping out
of line that this is what awaits you
this is what that's what lies ahead for
you
if you step out of line so just be quiet
and do what we tell you to do
and and that's that's why i described it
are you surprised that the leadership
folded kind of as quickly as it did
because i'm sure you saw it you may have
been in the chamber at the time tom
cotton did a really spectacular job of
repeating a speech that chuck schumer
gave about the filibuster i think it was
from you know five or eight years ago
something like that uh and then he
announced at the end by the way that was
chuck schumer that was in my speech and
it's like i don't think chuck was truly
this radically left and even nancy
pelosi in san francisco like obviously
she had some some of that but i don't
think she was totally like this are you
surprised that they folded not just the
guys that are you know watching out for
their back and just want to get
reelected but but that the leadership
just all went in on on the filibuster
well on the filibuster and yeah that
they're following just the sort of far
left on all of this stuff
i'm i'm not actually surprised you know
and i'll tell you why um so they have
all here's they've got a 50 50 senate a
very narrow majority in the house but
their base thinks they have a mandate to
like transform radically transform
america and so they're getting all this
pressure about get this stuff done and
you go back there and say well we can't
we don't have 60 votes and then the base
says to them well then get rid of the 60
vote thing okay because it's standing in
the way of our agenda and get it done
and if you don't get it done and that
means you're not with us and so after a
while they start beating on you so look
that
this fake voting rights thing is just
the issue they picked to have a
filibuster fight over but they were
prepared to do it over the debt ceiling
and they they were at some point talking
about doing it for immigration reform
you name it and they would find the
issue this is just the one they figured
we'd have the best chance to
to make a
straight faced argument on even there
wasn't a very good one and folding on it
i don't think chuck schumer had a choice
i really don't i think if chuck schumer
hadn't done this he was almost certainly
going to be primaried in new york uh in
his senate race and i think he thought
about that as he went through this uh
cycle and i think that's true for a lot
of their leadership and a lot of the
people that change their position on it
at the end of the day yes they're in the
leadership but they need to win
elections
to stay in that leadership and in that
case in the case of new york it means
the democratic primary where he most
definitely does not want to take on a
far left primary challenger that could
beat him that could beat him and so he's
trying to avoid that and i think it was
pretty clear to him if he didn't do this
that was without what was what was going
to happen to him yeah and there are even
rumors that aoc might be that person
just to give the devil is due i mean was
there anything in the voting rights act
that you thought was legit or do you
think the entire thing was designed for
all the mail and ballots all the no id
stuff all the illegals like was it all
designed just to keep them in power
forever or was there anything in there i
mean is there anyone in america today
that wants to vote that can't vote for a
legitimate reason or for an illegal i
don't think it's ever look i can't speak
for every state
in the union about exactly what their
voting right and laws are but there are
things in that bill that are mandated
that florida already does we already
have early voting here okay we have a
14-day period a 13-day period of early
voting and then you've got anybody can
vote by mail in florida you don't have
to prove that you're going to be out of
town or whatever and then you got
election day you go to your precinct and
from 7 a.m to 7 p.m as long as you're in
line before 7 pm you can vote that way
so it's never been easier but when when
i first ran for office in 2010 there was
still you know early voting was at one
point in the state limited didn't even
exist 20 years ago right then when i
first voted in 19 my first election 1989
there was no early voting if you wanted
to vote absentee you had to write a
letter saying i'm going to be out of
town or i'm having surgery or whatever
it is on that day
and uh so i don't think it's ever been
easier to either register or or to vote
in florida so it's not for me the big
problem is first of all there is no
concerted effort to deny access to the
ballot to anyone in america
some of those ideas they're talking
about okay uh you know ballot harvesting
allowing people to go out and just grab
ballots and put them we we had a huge
crisis about that here in florida and by
the way it was in a lot of times in
republican primary races where were
these people you would hire and they
would go out and they would collect 150
200 ballots and and and it just led to
all sort of shenanigans look we had a
mayor's race in miami overturned by a
judge a year after the election because
there was so much massive fraud on the
absentee ballot front a lot of it driven
by
ballot harvesting and so we ban those
practices here in florida and the
biggest challenge the biggest problem i
have is this sort of the federal
government is going to take over
elections which is what this is is a
huge problem for me big big problem
because you've now centralized election
authority in america and now it's at the
whim of whoever's in power
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell